chicken
[Music]
all right listeners
it's with a heavy heart that we
introduce
pillpod
episode 113.
Zizek has been summoned to appear before
the woke Council who shall decide his
fate and whether or not he shall be
canceled and we we are the woke counsel
in fact
three three CIS hat males and to be fair
I did actually attempt to reach out to
the trans Lobby and to the black woke
Elite to sit on the sentencing council
with us but unfortunately I was unable
to find their contact information isn't
that weird there wasn't no comment hey
well I'm latinx so that'll have to do
okay three CIS head males
two and a half weight
uh yeah they're too busy operating in
the shadows and pulling all the strings
I'm motion to change Victor to White for
the duration of the podcast
trans racialism can't do that so just in
case you're about to turn off this
reactionary podcast episode the trans
Lobby and the black woke Elite are to uh
what do you call interest groups that
are terrorizing us apparently according
to wait for it
slavoy Zizek Yes you heard that right
um Victor could you uh please for us
read the crimes against the accused yeah
so I would say that Zizek is accused of
being a reactionary
dog whistling two reactionaries
um I would say maybe he's charged with
being some kind of a
counter-revolutionary and I would say
worst of all he's charged with
transphobia
and becoming Jordan Peterson and maybe
becoming yeah maybe becoming Jordan
Peterson sympathetic it's the dialectic
this is the the closure of the dialectic
he debated exactly in order to become
him
um and I would also say that he he might
be also charged with
misrepresenting facts is he parroting
right wing talking points well he's
never had a problem with facts before
right we've had our discussions in the
past about why we like Zizek but whoever
it was who wrote this article
uh I'll go out and say it was dog [__]
feel free to disagree but his name is on
the top and maybe I'm getting duped by
some
uh high level ironic double speak but I
fact check many of these stories in less
than five minutes and no surprise
they're half truths
and like true hegelians we can announce
that every truth is in fact a partial
truth except that zizak interprets all
of his own partial truths in exactly the
same way Jordan Peterson would
as a an existential threat to reasonable
rational discourse what were the facts
I'm curious because I didn't have a
chance to fact check the only thing that
I fact checked
was the thing about the rapist
and that seemed to be true but I wasn't
sure yeah he offered a number of
examples here
one of them was I still think General
even if the even like to be clear even
if that is a true fact
I still
would agree that using it in this way
might have been problematic but it
seemed to be like the claim about the
person who got charged as a rapist and
then right before their sentencing I
think decided to transition a woman like
that as far as I could tell that's true
uh no it's not well it's true this is
where the half truth comes in
she was remanded to a woman's prison but
sentenced to a male prison yeah after a
protest no yeah I think there's some
protests well this the Scottish system
as I understand it only from you know
four minutes of Googling but they deal
with it on a case-by-case basis whereas
both conservatives and jijak are saying
the second you say I'm a woman you get
immediately put into a woman's prison
which is not at all the case oh okay
having done their fact or their case by
case analysis or whatever I don't know
if the protests changed what they would
have done but uh she is in a Men's
prison
right yeah but I mean I think I mean
doesn't he say that though that she is
in a man's prison
after protests yeah
so yes the protests happen but it's also
implying that it was because of the
protest it's also implying it's also
implying that whatever the what's the
head person of of Scotland called the
first Minister a sturgeon yeah sturgeon
apparently resigned because of this and
I don't think there's there's factual
basis for that either but in any case I
don't want to go over fact checking in
every case not really our area of
expertise our area of expertise is
adjudicating who should be canceled or
not
are self-appointed role I mean I think
don't the facts bear on that though of
course not we're theorists
wow I mean I I'm genuinely curious
because like I just didn't have a chance
to do a lot of robust fact checking so I
know that a lot of people were saying
that there were some on Twitter that
there were factual errors with it and it
seems like at least there were
definitely like a number of things that
were kind of like misrepresented truths
so like facts that start that like
initially seem right but when you look
into them a little bit more like I think
the thing about the Tavistock clinic for
example like the reason for it being
shut down
I think was misrepresented in the
article right and made it seem like the
reason it was shut down was because of I
guess abuses or lawsuits
and I think maybe that wasn't entirely
true well I know they did go through one
lawsuit but also he claims that they
were they were just running
pre-teens through the puberty blocker
Mill despite the fact that uh the clinic
is NHS or single-payer funded so they
were just they were only doing it for
money
but would you need to do it for money
again well I would say I'm not clear on
how it works there because there's
certainly Financial incentives and
dishing out treatments because we have
single-payer here and that's kind of the
case but was that the case
right I was gonna I didn't see that I
did see that as well and I will say that
like it seems a little silly to be like
well if it's single pair then there's no
Financial incentive I mean that's
obviously dumb like I mean any any
Public Health Care system is going to be
subject to neoliberalism so there's
clearly going to be Financial incentives
but it's not behind trying to extract as
much money from publicly funded Health
Care Systems as possible that's obvious
any thinking person should know that so
like I don't think because I don't think
because something is a single-payer
healthcare system there's no Financial
incentives at play that's clearly false
however he presents it as they're giving
puberty blockers to 13 year olds because
because of the financial incentive and
only for that reason probably a stretch
yeah probably a stretch maybe maybe I'm
going to be a little bit boring here
and say you know these the fact checking
here
you know it's not it doesn't matter it's
missing the point yeah the whole article
which I mean okay look at the title the
title is wokeness is here to stay the
first line is a response to an earlier
article that says wokeness is on the
Wane he says no it's here to stay okay
so maybe I've been grading a little too
much lately but I smell a thesis
statement that people are fact-checking
facts not looking at what points he's
marshalling these examples towards
making and then just claiming oh he's
wrong and then all these other things I
don't I don't know I'm not reacting with
the social media sphere like we're all
sitting in the same theater watching the
same room I have a little bit of trouble
you know going around Gathering people's
reactions together
because they're so dispersed but yeah I
have a feeling that people are reading
things into this article that are not
being claimed
and calling zizik a reactionary or a
transphobe for what he's saying here
well dude he said right wing he said
trans Lobby Okay so
and the trans Lobby when you when you
cite the or when you click the link that
he uses as a source right before this is
from the [__] Telegraph that the
trans Lobby is cowing doctors the
telegraph a right-wing rag that also I
clicked on the link and right advertised
to me right below this one was wish you
were taller you might be a psychopath
so anyway well there's well there's one
thing you know okay so I asked myself I
heard that and I asked myself what the
[__] is a trans Lobby what is a trans
Lobby and is there such a thing because
people seem to take such
um I don't know they they took so much
offense to this little term trans Lobby
so I was looking it up
and you know there are Charities and
non-profit organizations
that work with trans issues and bring in
lots and lots of money okay so is that
what he's talking about maybe it's not
the trans lobby but okay there's a group
called
stonewall.org it's a charity it was
started one of the founders is Ian
McKellen okay there's another one called
Kaleidoscope trust that's another one
there's another one called
National Center for transgender equality
in the states that they've had some
controversies they are also a
transgender activist non-profit
organization I mean there so to my mind
there are such things
as trans lobbies
a Lobby is a group of people trying to
collect money to further their goals
there's clearly people they Lobby the
government they Lobby the government in
order to influence public policy that's
the problem and the question I mean
that's not the problem that's what they
do and the question potential problem is
are they unduly influencing public
policy towards a minority
in a population right are they able to
push through legislate like it's no
different than an oil Lobby or a gun law
well it's a little it's just a lobby
lobby and a gun law but I mean is there
is there in their status of being a
Lobby is there evidence no difference
that the reason why I like Scotland
adopted self-identification as its
standard
is that is there evidence that the
results of lobbying efforts
yeah there's a whole there's a whole
thing over the um there's a whole
dispute I mean I got this from a website
called sex matters so I mean it seems
like they've made their choice on the
sex gender thing so take whatever you
want from that but they were pointing
out that a recent parliamentary decision
was released
I don't know if I can go into too much
detail about it but basically
and I don't really know all these
different terms in in British politics
either but they found that this this
public document that was published was
unduly influenced or they they were not
transparent about the groups the
non-government groups they were working
with
and it caused a huge stink
and the House of Lords had many uh had
many uh pundit Haram thing
um
but I mean there are groups out there
that have money and Lobby for these
issues yeah so what's the main artery
I'd rather using that term as
problematic that's what I'm saying is it
just because is it just because it's
just like you just did no you put them
right next to gun lobby which is what
billions billions of dollars and oil
Lobby tens of billions of dollars and
you go oh these are equal because
they're all lobbyist groups well I don't
think that Eric said anything about them
being equal right I mean I know he
didn't but that's it's actually it's the
implication this is why I'm saying we're
speaking in half truths but isn't that
isn't that kind of Eric's Point here
that people are reading into it a bunch
of claims that maybe aren't there right
so like you're saying oh my God you said
this that's kind of similar to
reactionaries therefore he must be
reactionary like that's really dumb and
anti-intellectual I mean the line is for
one thing clinicians are cowed by the
trans Lobby which interprets skepticism
regarding puberty blockers as a
conservative attempt to make it more
difficult for Trans individuals to
actualize their sexual identity that's
the line it appears in I don't see
anything I mean maybe with the Trans
Lobby maybe he should have said there
are many Lobby groups that work on lgbtq
plus and trans issues maybe his language
here is not as careful as it should be
but I don't see the fact of using a noun
as opening the doors to all of this
other nonsense yeah does he have to hold
our hands every time and be like Oh but
I'm not saying they're the same as at
the gun lobby I'm not saying they're the
same do we does he have to hold our
hands in every [__] thing that he
says you have to predict what your
reader is going to what conclusions
they're going to jump to and then and
then write a whole like footnote about
like but please don't misunderstand me
on this point like I don't know it again
it just feels like reading into it he
just said that word and people took
umbrage rightly so and then I looked it
up and there are in fact groups I I have
no idea about this stuff by the way so
don't don't get me wrong here I'm not
trying to say there is a the trans
lobbyists
that's how you influence public policy
if you want to do something good like
help people realize their identities
okay fine yeah you get a Lobby group
together and you Lobby the government
for public policy that
relieves whatever systematic violence is
being you know downloaded onto your
group hold up just hold on just hold on
hold on just to make it really explicit
for the dumb people listening Eric is
not saying that he agree or that he
disagrees with the efforts of these
groups that are trying to to make trans
rights to actualize trans rights he is
simply saying well there might be some
factual basis to the claim but he said
nothing about whether he agrees or
disagrees with those groups
yeah exactly I'm not saying that they're
I'm not making a moral claim that
they're just as they're not
reprehensible like the [__] oil Lobby
I would rather the oil Lobby didn't
exist exactly I know very little about
them and the issues they stand for sound
good to me exactly that there's these
little controversies that pop up and
they're complicated and I don't
understand them the amount of power the
amount of money all of this is
underwritten by this oh we have a Lobby
group that's deciding on governmental
and specifically clinical decisions that
makes a huge difference and you're
saying you're being too dumb to realize
that there is a difference here and
everyone should go do the fact checking
for themselves you know they're not
everyone who who had a part in writing
this article or editing it also knows
there isn't so you know there's a power
differential at play when you speak of a
Lobby group as if it's equivalent to a
gun lobby the United States gun lobby or
an oil Lobby anywhere else okay of
course well no no one including said
their equivalent
sure they're not he does the whole
article is about the trans Lobby and how
are they are keeping us asleep so that
we can get on in in capitalism well
that's gonna be your target you could
have any Target and this is the article
that you want to put out sorry let me
hedge further as as Lobby groups they
are all equally Lobby groups but they
are not equally powerful yeah they're
like and that's what that's what that's
all that seems that seems like an
obviously
Lobby groups but they're not equal in
power and influence right you got Exxon
Mobil money behind you then clearly
you're going to be more powerful than
any other [__] Lobby group yeah just
like just like the Marxist leninist
Party of Canada is equally a party to
the Conservative Party of Canada but
they have very different amounts of
power I know what you mean and I know
what you're saying the NDP is equally uh
do we have to do we have to is our
audience so yes we do this is a half
truth this is what this is but this is
the fact that they're cowing clinicians
citation needed and I understand I
understand why you're objecting to me
but articles do not suddenly exist in a
vacuum okay I agree with that I agree
with that too that's why I had to go
look it up because that was a stretch to
me too that he's claiming that there's
like specific pressure on clinicians
seems like a stretch to me I I don't
know about it and a good chunk of the
reaction focused on it so I felt the
need to look it up because why is I
think like 50 of the condemnation of
this article I've been hearing about is
from this like one throwaway noun
exactly and yeah I think I don't I I
don't again like I just I've been
remarking a lot of Articles essays
lately and I'm like it just seems to me
that people don't know how to read an
essay anymore look for the thesis look
for the points that each paragraph is
making and look at what evidence is
being marked towards those points and
don't read things into it that aren't
there I mean very simple things like
reading a piece
I don't remember the last time I've
agreed with Eric so much I agree with
him so much on this it's crazy when
there is a wide body of literature that
uses exactly the same points in exactly
the same order in exactly the same way
then you can say you can't really
honestly blame the reader for not
reading into something you kind of can
I'm sorry that we don't live in a
completely rational Society but no no I
I'm not before we before we focus on
these details any longer
I have a conspiracy theory that I would
like to air out
and I don't before but but don't you
think I I just want to say one thing
quickly about it I know you did that and
I know what it is
we should expect everyone in society to
be more rational people
what I'm gonna say I mean to some extent
yes that's part of the point but the
other point is just that
I am sorry like I understand that normal
people aren't like this but I am an
intellectual this podcast is a podcast
of intellectuals and from an
intellectual perspective I'm sorry but
like you don't just read things into
things
uh an intellectual from an intellectual
perspective you don't just say oh this
argument kind of reminds me of a
reactionary argument therefore it's
reactionary that's not true intellectual
effort
so like I'm sorry just because it's like
that I understand why people are
reacting that way I I get that but I I
would hope that we hold ourselves to a
higher standard
how admirable but Rhymes rhyme and this
Rhymes that's all I'm going to say
can I present my conspiracy theory to
you please and I think I agree with you
on this actually if I know where you're
going with it
um I don't want to be mistaken as a
probably you can already tell but from
my tone I don't want to be mistaken for
writing defense for Zizek because he's
my personal hero or some [__] like that
because he's not but that said
whoever wrote this article I think makes
a pretty blatant error on the lacanian
theory side of this article and one that
is at odds with most of zizek's own
writing on the con I don't know what
he's been writing lately because the
last book I read was uh
oh [__] what was that Hegel book the
black one
a recent book less than nothing less
than nothing Well less than nothing I
think it was 2016. anyway he referenced
the cover the color of the cover of the
book look I'm a visual person okay okay
the black so let me present my the black
book let me present my case at least
because
the big other does not exist is kind of
the thing that everybody knows about
Lacon and lakinian Theory it's a
signifier that can't signify anything
it's a lack and you subjectively to be a
subject you confer the big other with
meaning right
but it holds a place in the subject it's
not a person it's not your dad anymore
that was Freud it's a floating signifier
now here's what's [__] weird this
makes no sense the author of this
article says when he's talking about uh
the Telluride situation he says that the
big other
in the Telluride situation is the
Telluride Administration and that the
awokened Black Elite have terrorized the
big other which is the institutional
admin or or whomever
now that makes absolutely no sense
because the admin cannot be the big
other and Zizek I think would know that
because
I checked it
um here let me get this open this is
what g-jack says about the big other and
I'm sorry I'm going to quote at length
it'll be annoying but I want to draw a
contrast between the way that he talks
about the big other at least in his old
work compared to the way he talks about
the big other in this in this article
um today it is a common place that the
lacanian subject is divided crossed out
identical to a lack in a signified chain
however the most radical dimension of
lacanian theory lies not in recognizing
this fact but in realizing the big other
the symbolic order itself is also barred
crossed out by a fundamental
impossibility structured around an
impossible or traumatic kernel around a
central lack
now none of this should be new we know
this stuff without this lack in the
other the other would be a closed
structure and the only possibility open
to the subject would be is radical
alienation in the other
so it is precisely this lack in the
other which enables the subject to
achieve a kind of de-alienation called
by Lacon separation not in the sense
that the subject experience is that now
he has separated from uh forever from
the object by the barrier of language
but the object is separated from the
other itself that the other hasn't got
it hasn't got the answer that is to say
it is in itself blocked and Desiring
that there is also the desire of the
other again another famous lacanian
formulation this lack in the other gives
the subject so to speak a breathing
space it enables him to avoid the total
alienation and the signifier not by
filling out his lack by allowing him
sorry but by allowing him to identify
himself his own lack with the lack of
the other
so Zizek wrote this the other's not real
it's the functioning of the symbolic and
the sub the subconscious experience of
you know first of all your own lack but
then the lack of the other
gives you that sort of de-alienation you
know the other is not closed and
fundamentally cannot be closed so
I'm suggesting if that's the structure
of the symbolic how could you ever ever
confuse
the other with a capital a
with the actual administration of a
university Department that would be
impossible right
hmm
well I I I got us I got yeah I get that
sense that the big other is is like the
symbolic field
and I I don't know I imagine that the
administrative authority of Telluride is
is is the the shaper of that symbolic
field in this particular situation
they're they're the ones whose demands
are being heard in a certain way right
now that makes sense with only one of
the references because he goes on to say
that the black woke activists
are terrorizing the big other so what
you're they're terrorizing the symbolic
order that you project to oversee your
own desire
because that's impossible
because that isn't real first of all it
isn't real and second it oversees the
split in the subject himself and this is
not like a little side bit from zizek's
writing either it's in every book it's
the reason he's academically famous at
least before he was YouTube famous was
for mixing this lacanian subject with
the neo-marxist or uh
uh altuzarian notion of ideology like he
would not get this wrong unless there's
something very wrong with him on the
other hand through it on the other hand
let me say this on the other hand it is
a very miscomet or a common
misconception of Lacon and Zizek and I
know because my audience brings it up
all the time and I correct it when
they're like yeah Google's the big other
no there is no big other it's a function
not a thing
and if Zizek wrote this either he forgot
his own UVA which would be very [__]
scary and we should be very worried
about him
because he no longer knows his own
formulation that he's famous for or this
was Ghost written
or it was written by Chad GPT and then
he agreed for some reason to put on his
name on it without reading it carefully
so I don't know but I would like some I
wish we had some verification that he
wrote this the rest of it doesn't really
feel very Zizek
but there's no I don't have like
evidence to put on that but the fact
that he made that
what I think is an error or just like a
maybe he was simplifying for the
audience I don't know but it seems like
something huge to get wrong if he wrote
this himself
you know what that makes me think that
because I'm looking at that paragraph
right now and it's like in Brackets it
says the telleride administration
Authority in this case
that feels like it could be an editorial
decision like they added someone was
like that they added it in they're like
I want you to connect this rhetoric back
to the article that you're talking about
you should you should say even though
the editor doesn't understand
the point like the psychoanalytic point
he's making and he's like
like the fact that it's in parentheses
is interesting to me I don't know is
there anything else in parentheses
that's sus well I mean I don't know I'd
have to look over it again but that was
that that was intro because I'm looking
at the paragraph you're talking about
where he actually says the big other
corresponds to the teller Administration
and it's just interesting because I
could imagine this paragraph Without
those for instance this is
um
let's see and maybe it would be
different
one paragraph later he goes this super
ego structure then which is Freudian
fine whatever he does do Freudian I
don't know why you would deviate though
from Lacon if you're gonna start with
Lacon because Lacon would be you're
you're doing you're doing Jewish songs
by feeling the guilt like it makes you
feel better and more comforted to put
yourself into guilt
than having this super Surplus enjoyment
why do so what does he's saying that
other people are doing this to you the
whole point is that people do it to
themselves
I guess the super ego names the
psychological mechanism through which
this occurs Surplus enjoyment is when I
actually say you know I am nothing or
like you know I'm white so I'm I'm just
obviously racist and complicit in the
system that's that's me now I'm getting
super egoic kind of I'm getting Surplus
enjoyment from positioning myself in
that way because then it goes on to
allow me to say the things I want to say
anyway and it makes no difference all
right it's the Surplus enjoyment coming
out of me excoriating myself which is
what these sort of Silicon Valley
self-help kind of uh racist workshops do
for for white Business Leaders right it
puts them in a position where they can
respond to the demands of the superego
they can experience their Surplus
enjoyment and by positioning themselves
in that way then they can go back to
their businesses and contribute to this
restructuring of the symbolic field of
the big other maybe the Telluride
administrative Authority had had one of
those um had one of those uh I am racist
workshops come through recently I don't
know but those things seem like again
separate different parts of very similar
things but you know big other superego
all those things are different it
doesn't make sense for someone else to
terrorize
the symbolic order itself though I don't
get it it's the explanation of how a
minority can impose its views how the
lgbtq plus trans Black Elite all these
words he's using here it's like because
because he's saying that these are
minority positions
that how do they have an impact on the
overall say humanist liberal culture
that's opinion you're you're adding all
this he just says the telleride
administration is this is the symbolic
order in parenthesis just I'm just
taking things from other parts of this
article they're in there
but this explanation here
I think it works for those other things
too he just happens again he's the the
example he's currently discussing
happens to be he's gone back to the uh
was it was it Vincent Lloyd
yeah Vincent Lloyd the Telluride group
that's why he's saying it that's why
he's applying these terms to this
situation
but it equally goes for the other
examples now so we have the claim that
wokeness is a religious cult
and
I don't know what we think about this
well yes it is a religious call yeah if
you pick all of the worst examples of
wokeism then yes and look I wanted to
distress this to the listeners we know
these people
and we probably know more of them better
than you do by virtue of doing a
Humanities uh graduate degree because
they do run their workshops and they do
pretty much everything that Zizek claims
they do which is make a bunch of
impossible and contradictory rules that
are about you know identity politics and
at the extreme end it does get insane
because some of them are very loud and
they see microaggressions in every
shadow and we know these people but
they are not most people and they are
not running and they are not running the
show in the University either because
the show is run by Sunshine List
bureaucrats who give University Building
contracts to their cousins so we could
give a whole bunch of personal anecdotes
that would validate this argument that
says woke extremists are annoying but
they are loud exceptions even if you
enter the the dreaded gender studies
Department
like I mean that ironic okay so premises
of this article though are all based on
very loud
cherry-picked exceptions to say that the
radical left is out of control
okay so I I think I agree with you and
this this is like
the very you you basically articulated
what I think is like the main response
that kind of leftists make to the whole
problem of so-called problem of wokeness
and cancel culture they're kind of like
well either it doesn't really exist or
it's like way less of a problem than you
actually think it is like that's kind of
the standard response I think that
response misses something important well
I agree with you and I have been around
I think what's missed in that response
is I think it is clearly having a real
effect on society that that is that very
small minority is having a real effect
on society
and I think the way that we can
articulate that effect is I think
that and I've noticed this anecdotally
from talking to people
it does have a chilling effect on people
who are kind of in the middle like the
majority of people who are kind of like
well I don't really care about this and
there's an effect in this way
I know there are a lot of people who
will kind of say things like oh that
claim that those people are making or
like that claim that this activist group
is making kind of doesn't really make
sense to me
but I don't want to seem like I'm
against
like leftism I don't want to seem like
I'm reactionary so I'm just gonna stay
quiet and I think there are a lot of
people
who kind of don't really agree with some
of these cultural
I don't know or they at least have
questions about it where they'll be like
I'd rather just say nothing
then argue about it because ultimately I
don't really care
so the effect of that is something that
behavioral economists would call belief
falsification
where you have people who kind of aren't
really being upfront about what they
actually think because they don't want
to take the chance that they'll be that
they'll be penalized for saying
something that isn't in the kind of woke
ethos
um there's this guy on Twitter that I
saw itai sure I think he articulated it
really well when he was like you know
everyone says that it doesn't really
exist but the real problem is just that
when you impose penalties or there could
be potential penalties where you'll have
kind of a mob Behavior reaction to it
um people there might be some people
who'll be willing to pay that penalty
but a lot of people won't right so
they'd rather just not risk saying
anything that could potentially be
seemed be uh seemed like it would be
um you know against something and yeah
that still functions even if the actual
people who have the crazy beliefs are a
super small minority if they're loud
enough it's going to have that effect
yeah and what I see each each
each of these examples he's giving
people are reading these like saying
look how like like you even you just
said pills like look how out of control
the radical left is that's not what he's
saying here yeah if anything Zizek is
the radical left right and he calls
wokeness he says wokeness deserves our
criticism together with its opposite new
populism and religious fundamentalism
it's another one of these things that
deserves our criticism again the thesis
of this article is wokeness is not on
the Wane it is here to stay it is being
normalized and this is why it deserves
our criticism together with these other
things the Opposites the obscenity of
new populism and religious
fundamentalism right he's not giving
these
examples to show look how out of control
Wellness is he gives these examples to
make a very specific point
after each of them you just said you
know okay the point about the religious
aspect
he makes a transition from the trans
Lobby point and here's his transitional
phrase as if interest group agitation
which is a synonym for the trans Lobby
thing he was just talking about as if
interest group agitation and the
compulsions of capital which he's saying
are married together here in this
previous example the compulsions of
capitalism and trans Lobby groups and
that as if that weren't enough wokeness
can also draw upon reserves of religious
strength and then he's going to give
another example of this speech that
happened at London's goldsmiths College
where somebody was talking about in
front of a feminist society and some
Muslim Students and the Muslim Students
decried the speaker and the feminists
sided with the Muslims and then he
concludes wokeness operates as a
secularized religious Dogma with all the
contradictions it implies because
the form of his sort of this example I
guess feminism now is standing for
wokeness there's a lot of avatars the
formally they're similar the two
discourses are formally similar in the
last example where he was talking about
the um the workshop he was saying the
forms were different the seminar that
the 12 carefully chosen youngsters were
in was of a different form than this
person right wrote their book in right
he's that's why he's saying seminar and
workshop are formally distinct and they
got their wires crossed here we see the
formal relationship between religious
fundamentalism on the one side and
wokeness on the other side that's what
he's showing with this new point but
again like it's like then people are
reading these examples taking them out
of context and making making g-shek use
them to say something he's not actually
saying that's the only thing like I'm
again I'm not [__] defending him here
I'm just
really what you're saying is read the
text carefully that's what I'm saying
I'm like don't like yeah
I don't want to be a [__] drag on
people right react to things however the
[__] you want to react to things I don't
give a [__] but I mean there's also
people's lives yeah we haven't met
g-jack he's really just like he's
basically like a a Greek god to us we've
never met him probably never will but he
is a real person and as are other people
on the internet who get a quote unquote
canceled and so if you're gonna you know
effects of your of your misreadings of
things that's what I want to say uh
broadly you can you can have a problem
with the with the factual errors he
makes and I do have a problem I found
that first paragraph or section or
whatever
I felt like I was uneasy with with the
way that he was phrasing things I didn't
like it I thought he went a little bit
too far but oh his overall point I think
and look I understand that there are
people who are going to react to this
who aren't
intellectuals we went to school we are
doing our phds finished our phds we're
in the business of reading texts
and I think Eric is here defending the
value and the care of what we do which
is read texts carefully
oh there's my Surplus enjoyment I'm not
an intellectual I'm stupid I'm stupid I
just try hard that's the secret to
that's the secret to looking smart is
just trying hard you don't need to be
smart you just need to try hard that's
all and I'm trying hard to understand
what he's trying to say in this article
and then try to like sort of
I don't know correlate it with some of
the reaction I've caught and since this
article has been published
and they seem to me
you know okay here's a huge figure like
g-shek they are often targeted by cancel
and they can you know they can they can
weather it but you know people who
aren't g-jack cannot weather it if we
get canceled for this we will not be
able to weather it and we will lose our
nice little uh we'll lose our nice
little side project okay but I mean
that's that's the thing if you if you
misread somebody's work and then you put
the ideas out there and they cannot
handle the backlash then you've just
done something immoral basically right
and if they can't handle it well then
fine that's just all fun and games right
until somebody
goes broke because they got canceled
it's all the New Movement now Brokenness
right you can't be woke anymore because
you're just [__] broke and that
doesn't matter I don't think this is
even an overreaction because he's very
contented these are cherry-picked
examples we've already only been through
two of them which have a lot to be
desired even in the fact that it brings
them up but he just jumps from that one
to the next one then it's the feminists
and then it's the the woke Black Elite
and if you're feed brained enough to
just see these examples on your timeline
think that these are the things worthy
of response
then of course you're going to think
this is way out of control that's just a
basic perceptual fact that if that's
what you see that's what you'll think
the world is and if you want to claim
this figures as the the decay of Western
culture which a right-wing article would
do exactly the same in exactly the same
order with a slightly different
conclusion then you're a dupe and only
reacting to that is is is dupish
because it's a spectacleized distraction
from the real problem with universities
Zizek is laying all of this at this this
unnamed grad student in an article that
ran the workshops as the real problem
with universities and wokeness is
keeping us asleep as opposed to the
university if we're gonna do some you
know quote-unquote material analysis the
university run by hand picked
institutional bureaucrats who capitalize
in profit off of Education don't give a
[__] about hap what happens in a seminar
room whether someone gets
kicked out of their seminar for being uh
for for doing microaggressions as long
as everyone's paying their tuition
so why why is that not the article why
don't we look at that instead of being
afraid of the terrorist religious woke
cult
which is now like he's he's reacting
he's reacting to a Twitter timeline I
bet he doesn't have Twitter but this is
a Twitter reaction I mean I agree if you
want to go if you want to find an
example of the quote worst combination
of politically correct badgering with
the brutal calculation of financial
interests go to your local University
and look up the Board of Governors and
there you will find it politically
correct badgering this school is green
this school's inclusive of Multicultural
with brutal calculation of financial
interest surprise it's a [__] degree
Mill and these people are connected with
construction and whatever other
government construction connected yeah
okay I I agree with that maybe this
article should have been about that but
unfortunately he uses that in the
Tavistock example of the of this Clinic
as opposed to at a university but it
works there too I think politically
correct that's better probably in the
university and financial interests yeah
worst combination as it and then which
he also restates as interest group
agitation compulsions of capital coming
together to form a horrible child which
is shaping public policy unfortunately I
will say something that maybe
you'll have to cut out but I I do feel
that like I was gonna say this before on
the on the point about the trans Lobby
or whatever like I agree it's it's it's
the implication of it like reading
between the lines sounds bad
and like when you're just talking about
money like obviously
it's ridiculous
but I think there is such a thing as
cultural power that exists and I think
that there's a really I think it's a
pretty smart analysis
that when you look at kind of the
polarization especially in in the United
States where you have a bunch of
right-wingers who are really mad at the
left because they say the left has all
the power
and the left is really mad at the right
because they're like well you have all
the power but if you look at it it's
actually kind of convincing to say that
the right in the States has all the
political power right the control the
Supreme Court that like the system is
skewed to for them to win
but then when you look at cultural power
like Hollywood like the music industry
like that is all kind of like whatever
you could call like woke adjacent like
the cultural power is being defined by
the left and the one example that I
found really interesting was the
reaction to Dave Chappelle's uh comedy
special which I didn't think was that
bad
but what I thought was most interesting
was like Dave Chappelle and all these
comedians have been saying bad [__]
about women about black people like
they're they're making jokes at the
expense of women but it's like the
moment you make a joke about trans
people there is like an outsized
reaction
and I think that that it is just in my
opinion true
that for whatever reason the trans issue
has a kind of cultural veto power that
other disadvantaged groups don't seem to
have and if you actually listen to Dave
Chappelle special that's the point he's
actually making in the special he's kind
of saying like hey when I was I'm a
black person I never got to just tell
people that they were racist and that
they would get canceled but for some
reason the trans issue does have a
cultural veto power that you say
anything that is like adjacently
critical of the way that trans issues
are kind of proceeding there's it's a
kind of lightning rod that talking about
other disadvantaged groups isn't now
that doesn't mean that I'm not
sympathetic with the struggles of all of
these groups equally
I still think you can be sympathetic to
the struggles of all these groups
equally and still kind of notice oh one
of them seems to have a kind of cultural
veto power that's kind of interesting
and I do think that there is more for
some reason on the trans side of things
okay now that you've made your point
um do you want that cut out or do you
want to leave it in
it depends on how you guys think it
sounded okay so my response
is the other more the other worst line
in this article was that like giving
hormone blockers is uh just across the
board woke capitalism right
and the reason I think specifically
this is more sensitive especially at the
moment like aside from just being
accused of being groomers every day is
that
he's extending in this article
especially in the first half this
fantasy that trans people have this
seamless access to health care and
people are just [__] choosing to
transition On Any Given Friday because
they feel like it so that's clearly not
true this is supposed to be along the
lines of the argument which is his like
psychoanalytic argument it goes back to
the 90s that sexual identity is and like
identity generally it's lack it's not
like a thing and it's supposed to be
confusing to go through puberty and it's
because there's ultimately not a kernel
at the center of the subject that says
um you know M or f on it I'm really this
yeah but while he's dueling with the
Phantasm of gender identity he just
extends in my mind the reactionary
fantasy the gender is merely a matter of
whim
for transgender people that it's
equivalent to a consumer choice
so this theory
is already not made at exactly the wrong
time because of what's going on
legislatively in both uh Britain and the
United States right now and I struggle
to imagine anyone who knows
any trans person
would put that on paper like now I mean
damn
I guess the theory the theoretical
argument
is that what you're rebelling against
you're rebelling against your birth
gender which is merely
producing Surplus
enjoyment
and even if you want to couch that
argument he couches it in in just total
ignorance suggesting that the capitalist
system has made it possible for Trans
people to just transition wherever they
feel like it or to put off gender
assignment by paying for it instead of
the fact that they have to pay a much
higher cost than any other medical thing
not necessarily monetary cost but you
have to run through an obstacle course
of approvals to get it treated in the
first place and why the [__] is he
saying this it's too easy
to transition it's a consumer Choice
it's too easy we have to make it harder
right now
because that's what the [__]
right-wing legislators are doing every
day
yeah no that's really bad and I think
like I do think that there's
like especially right now in the states
with kind of like making laws that a
doctor can't decide you know even if a
doctor thinks it's it's appropriate that
like you can't give children like yeah
that's all super [__] well the cat
the doctors are all just part of the
system that's all that's the only thing
he says about doctors doctors are I mean
they're I mean serving capitalism that's
it they don't know anything
they don't know anything I sitting on my
[__] phone here now everything I mean
yes I also think it would be silly to
say that there's not an incentive there
though like so there's an inside that
doesn't mean [__] medical treatment
of course of course well he's talking
about kids the puberty blocker thing
yeah he was talking about kids with the
people he's talking about children and
the way again this example the point
he's making with it is you know puberty
blockers are being like this is just
even this is almost a logical argument
and the example is an illustration of
the point right so the point is well the
illustration I I'll start with Tavistock
right is giving troubled youngsters and
autistic Youth and then other people
like can I just stop you for one second
delay my favorite my favorite Twitter
response to the article was
uh someone said like the most shocking
thing about this article is the amount
of times that shizek refers to children
as youngsters
autistic and troubled youngsters yeah
it's weird who who may have okay so they
maybe identif maybe diagnosed with
gender dysphoria maybe diagnosed with
uncertainty about their sexuality which
is considered you know in this diagnosis
this is considered
maladaptive this is considered abnormal
right and what he's saying is no this is
not good not not this isn't bad just
because puberty blockers could have you
know horrific effects later on down the
road this is bad because quote there is
nothing abnormal in sexual confusion
what we call sexual maturation is long
complex and mostly an unconscious
process
a full violent tensions reversals blah
blah blah the point is giving puberty
blockers on the assumption that you just
need a little more time to decide what
your sexual identity is is
like just that whole thing is is just
that's not the case
and the misunderstanding of what's up
with my claims because I don't have a
good understanding on different
countries trans health care though first
of all I don't think that Eric's making
that claim I wasn't sure Eric is just
saying that that's what jijic is saying
he's not saying yeah that that's what he
believes he's saying that this is what
she's like is saying there is nothing
abnormal in sexual confusion so why are
you giving kids you're calling sexually
confused puberty blockers that's his
[__] point it's not that everyone's
doing this to have a stock is just the
tip of the iceberg we should look into
this that's not his [__] point you're
taking the example out of context and
using it towards an argument that jijic
is not making he's using again that's my
point he's using the example sorry
he's using the example to generalize his
other point that your sexual identity is
a matter of whim and everyone's just
changing it too fast
no he's not again he didn't say that
because his first example here's a quote
the point here is that there's no easy
solution because sexual identity is in
itself not a simple form of identity but
a complex Dimension full of
inconsistency something that can no way
be established by a direct reference to
how we listen listen I know why that
rapist was just changing genders and
getting put in a women's imprison
because because there's this big other
logic where you declare what you feel
you are and you are registered as what
you want to be he's again he's pushing
back against that and saying no you
can't establish your identity with
direct reference to how you feel it is
not a consumer Choice thing that's again
that the first example is meant to
establish that point the second example
is to say there is nothing abnormal in
sexual confusion it is not gender
dysphoria it is not abnormal development
it is normal for everyone to have the
questions long into your adulthood and
we should not be giving puberty blockers
to people who have a little bit of
confusion about whether they want to
declare themselves this or that or play
with this and that toy or have this in
that career that's normally associated
with and again right citation needed
because many gender clinics across the
West doctors feel compelled to adopt an
unquestionably affirmative approach
that's his premise which is never
questioned and he goes with it to more
than half of tavistock's income came
from the treatment of youngster sexual
troubles in short what we have here is
the worst combination of politically
correct badgering with the brutal
calculation of financial interests the
use of puberty blockers not specific
puberty blockers not individual cases
where they're required no the use of
puberty blockers is yet another case of
vote capitalism so you can be as
charitable as you want to it but the
words are still there
this is a financial interest situation
to him
the reason that it is what capitalism is
because it's a consumer choice I
definitely had issues with that framing
but I still think that if you take up
the context of the broader article like
Eric is doing I think ultimately his
bigger point is articulated by what Eric
was saying yes I think that those lines
and like I said I like I said from the
beginning I had issues with that first
section
uh there were connect there were
implicit connections made
about the power of certain groups about
the influence that these clinics are
having
um yeah so I would agree that I have an
issue with that and I but I also agree
with Eric that
it's not actually that important to the
main argument he's making well no he it
is he says this is what I'm thinking it
is the premise unquestioning affirmative
approach which is just to say that it's
too easy to be trans translobby got
everyone out there being trans and
Friday and transiting back on Monday
honestly I don't even I don't even know
what to say
I think he's just saying doctors aren't
even uh doctors aren't going to push
back against that that's what I think
that's all he's really saying doctors
are just well you just sit back and you
think doctors know what they're talking
about citation needed for what doctors
feel the point is doctors like are not
to be trusted on this because doctors
are all in the pocket of big trans
but that doesn't you know that's not a
premise for the point that it's there's
nothing abnormal in sexual confusion who
the [__] is you to say this puberty
blocker medical issue
a psycho a psychoanalyst that's who it
is
a lacanian psychoanalyst who's written
about this without g-shek interjecting
himself into this conversation because
anecdotally I know it can be a
humiliating difficult long-waisted
unafor long waitlisted and unaffordable
process but Zizek is just so sure then
in whatever he calls the West it's just
too easy
you you we got our trans listeners hope
out there and I hope they're hearing
this your problem is you just have it
way too easy
do you think that's really what I'm
saying is I don't think he's saying it's
too easy I think he's saying you know
okay maybe I don't think he's saying
this but whether or not you put you put
put or remove barriers in front of
things like this in front of things like
puberty blockers you think they're bad
okay put up barriers put up barriers
think they're good remove the barriers
remove the barriers making it easier
either option is premised on a
wrong-headed notion of sexual identity
that's the point not that you know the
okay there maybe there's some sub points
in fact checking about how widespread
this practices among doctors I don't
know why the [__] that's even important
for this argument but apparently it is
how widespread is this practice is
Tavistock just the tip of the iceberg
why aren't doctors getting involved in
stopping this horrible stuff doctors
don't give a [__]
these clinics that are half in the
private sector don't give a [__]
like I don't know like the point to me
seems like he's making a point again
about sexual identity from his lacanian
perspective I also got us a point about
the widespreadness of this practice you
kept saying citation needed I just like
did a quick Google search I got like a
WebMD article from 2021 that's
questioning some of the same things as
jijic is questioning and I don't know I
don't know enough about WebMD but my
understanding is it's not like an anti
no the citation I need is that doctors
are cowed is his word or they're living
in widespread fear so they just give
everybody everything that they ask for
in every case well here's
here's it says leading experts on
transgender medicine are accusing trans
activists of muffling their concerns
about the quality of evaluations of
adolescents and young adults with gender
dysphoria that's the first line
yeah I mean I mean I don't know it's
WebMD maybe WebMD is some kind of an
anti-trans reactionary group it's
possible I don't know if that's just
from a quick Google search
I just you kept saying citation needed
so I decided to do a quick Google I'm
not saying you should Professor trans
activists on every prescription I'm also
saying you should not trust a Slovenian
psychoanalyst on every prescription what
I'm saying is if there's anyone to trust
then it would be the doctors and he just
said doctors are all compromised by
capitalism yeah I mean I don't think
it's such a I don't think it's it is
such a stretch that you know like you
can request medication you can request
it like beyond what the doctor like I
can go in and get my dose of my ADD meds
or my depression meds or whatever I can
go and get my doses up it's just for
asking for it and okay maybe that's okay
with when it comes to those kind of
psychological things maybe I don't know
I could overdo it but with puberty
blockers you don't want that to be a
just ask situation
but I don't find it unbelievable that
many Clinic clinics especially in our
sort of current Healthcare situation
would be open to you know just the whole
idea of yeah like we'll just give them
whatever they ask for you know I get the
money from the drug companies for that
just like you know that's you know you
can be a huge and and if I say no
representative and go and get vets to
sell your dog food for money and if I
say no there might be like activists on
Twitter who are going to try to cancel
me for not being affirmative and
accepting
like that I'm just saying like that that
Social Power I think it does exist
there's no one that has yeah Google
alerts set to
whenever a depressed person does
something that that this now needs to
become a legislative or in this case now
this needs to be a theoretical issue
this is a theoretical issue I mean again
the depressed it's not easy to be trans
medically legally now especially or
social totally agree and this is made
into even currently right now this is
made into a theoretical debate about you
know what's fundamentally a medical
decision and then also a legal in a
social circumstance
I don't I don't even know what to say
this is I mean I think look I do think
that there's whether you want to debate
the reality of sexual identity from a
laconian perspective go [__] do it
somewhere else
okay that's okay like I'm sorry but I
just like so strongly disagree with you
hold on we came to them I I
look I just this is like a line that
really pisses me off sometimes when
people are like trying to stop people
from debating things I'm sorry like we
are people who study philosophy we study
Theory what we do is debate and think
about stuff and the idea that something
all the things we debate affect people's
lives there's tons of things that we
debate that affect people's lives and to
be like no this issue I'm sorry is like
affects this group of people's lives too
much that we can't talk about it or we
can't raise questions about it just
seems
like not
like anti-intellectual and like not
really like living up to the values that
I care about well you know what man [__]
it on this point okay I am
anti-intellectual and honestly I need a
[__] break
I don't know how this episode is going
but I almost feel like maybe we're not
gonna be able to release it
uh maybe I mean I want to look at like
for my assessment it would be you know
from from what I've seen the crit the
critique and the fact of from the fact
checking angle is like the line he says
here puberty brought blockers were
administered to almost all children for
sent for assessment at Tavistock
apparently that wasn't exactly true that
was one thing that I saw fact checked
that it's I really got that yeah wasn't
true exactly yeah exactly but then okay
but then the second question then is is
like okay well is that that's an
inaccuracy in an example in a fact he's
presenting to what degree does that
undermine the point he's making along
the way like that's why I keep asking
the questions about like okay yeah like
the fact checking the example is great
like okay yeah you've given like some
ammunition to right-wingers who want to
take this [__] out of context and use it
to make a totally different point
is making off and putting their own
point on it which is going to be
something awful exactly and again that's
the argument well we can't you know do
leftist Theory because in 10 years right
Wingers are just going to pick it up and
use it to [__] mind [__] us and and
to further deeper into capitalism or
something like that right like that's
not a good argument yeah exactly and
this is actually it's funny the second
paragraph in this WebMD article is like
uh well clinicians who have raised the
warning flags say that the health of
young people is their primary concern
activists worry that open questioning of
the situation will fuel anti-transl
legislation further stigmatizing trans
Youth and like I think that's exactly
the dynamic that
kind of stifles discussion and I get
that I'm actually sympathetic to that I
think the laws that are being passed in
the United States to like stop like
people stop doctors from being able to
prescribe these things it's like super
[__] up it's like if your doctor
thinks that this is appropriate like
they should be able to do that but what
I hate is just like that you can't raise
questions about it that you can't be
like does this make sense that the
moment you do that you're just going to
be labeled
as uh like transphobic or anti-trans
like but but I so I get it
um but I think that like if there are
people who have some concerns about
these things I guess to me it just seems
like a legitimate line of questioning
uh I think it's possible to be like
maybe people who want to debate this uh
can debate this well at the same time
being pro-trans rights I think you
should be that I think that should be
like a an intellectually possible
position to have
yeah like
I I really
you know like I don't want these things
to be a problem yeah and the the worst
thought in my head is that if if I bring
up a topic am I going to be creating
grief for someone who this matters to
well I'm doing my armchair thing over
here am I going to be creating problems
for people or am I going to be making it
easier for people who do want to cause
problems to like jump in and open up and
run the run with the debate and then
like create this politicized issue where
or a section of the population is then
put under Fire like I would hate myself
if I perpetuated that kind of stuff yeah
same but I mean the problem is you know
the social media 21st century these
conversations are going on all the time
whether you take part in them or not
right like me adding my voice to this
debate is not really going to create
problems for people I wish people would
just stop talking about this stuff and
just like accept the fact that there's
no problems here you know like yeah we
need Universal Health Care you know that
would help everybody that's not a that's
not a trans issue that's not a racial
issue that would just help everyone yeah
right having like equal representation
in the politics right like that I don't
know there's there's a lot of things a
lot of emancipatory ideas
that could help everybody
but you know when people come to these
trans issues they're like well I don't
want my system funding these operations
that's like Jesus [__] that's so selfish
I can't believe that line of argument
yeah so you think that making these
things covered by Government funding is
going to make everyone suddenly run out
and get like sexual transition surgery
that's insane obviously we legalized
weed in Canada I'm sure the level of
pot-headedness did not [__] go up
everyone who was a pothead before is
still a pothead and maybe some people
who are weed curious or now I'm smoking
a little more weed than they did before
it's not it's such a slippery slope
argument when you do that I hate it I
hate it but yeah they are important
issues and they need to be I mean to go
back to to go back to like's Claim about
you know the fact that everyone is a bit
confused sexually like to be more
critical of him I suppose you could say
that you know is it really the same like
like is everyone equally sexually
confused like I think that's clearly not
true right so I think like I think well
there's a grain of Truth to the idea
that everyone's sexual development is
can everyone's sexual development is
confusing there are often ambiguities
and reversals
but I think it would also be weird to
just say it's the same for everyone it's
not the same for everyone like clearly
clearly people who have symptoms
associated with gender dysphoria it's
going to be a lot different level it's
going to be a different magnitude of
confusion so I don't think it's
necessarily right to just equate those
things that everyone has those same
um although maybe we maybe what he's
saying is that the structure of sexual
development is similar for all of us
it's just that certain reversals or
confusions are more magnified for some
okay I'm back
triggered triggered podcast host
walks out of the room yeah you have to
take a little walk you have to take
walks out of the room because he was so
shocked by all of our transphobia over
here that he just like needed to take
walk because he's such a white knight
who's here to defend the trans the trans
trans people from our transphobia and
I'm an anti-intellectual
the smallest little limb and suggests
that
trans people want to be able to go to
their doctor and get their meds and just
not be trending every other [__] day
because conservatives have
Trans on their Google Alerts so that
anytime any trans person is anything it
becomes a trending topic on whether or
not they should exist or not how about
that I mean I agree with you oh my God
wait wait till uh wait till post
production you said before you got back
I pretty much exactly yeah just like
that we should have Universal Health
Care that's exactly I'm Gonna Leave It
All in because I broke character so
that's an interesting that's exactly
that's exactly the claim that everyone
should agree with and I think everyone
does agree with
now I'm sure that like you know the con
like Zizek would probably say or maybe
the conservative would say
like I'm not I'm talking about children
that maybe there's something specific
about children and look there is
actually like a question there about
you know if children aren't allowed to
make a bunch of decisions why are they
allowed to make this decision I mean
that doesn't seem like an unreasonable
question to ask no doctors are making
this decision but doctors are being
cowed
well no no but actually a lot of the
that's not so yes doctors are making
recommendations but ultimately I'm
pretty sure in Canada and I think out in
the UK situation like children could
make the decision without their parents
consent right whereas most other
decisions
that children have to make their parents
have to consent to it
I mean some people make decisions when
they're young and they're happy with
them for their whole lives and I'm
jealous of that because I know if I
would make a big decision like this I
would hate my younger self for locking
me into this path but that's just me I
don't even have tattoos I have to I
can't commit to any [__] [__] so
that's me but other people it works for
them but I don't know I'm sure a lot of
people that saves their lives and it's
and it makes them so I mean it's just
I think this thing about cowing doctors
and they're giving puberty blockers to
anyone who just [__] strolls in and
asks for them hey I don't think that's
actually happening I don't know how
widespread that is all the stuff pills
was saying earlier
but
can we get to the Lacon bit at the end
is that okay
I don't know if we should release this
episode
I feel like I'm gonna get canceled hard
for them
this is the big other talking
by the trans Lobby so the lacanian
argument he brings up what is this from
uh seminar 10 or 11. there's a Freud
story about a dad
sorry it's been a while since I read it
so I hope I get this right the dad feels
responsible for his son's death he falls
asleep next to
the son's body I think it's like an
infant
and a fire starts in the house
and the father is dreaming
and in the dream the child is burning
alive and says father can't you see I'm
burning
and the lacanian interpretation of this
and then the father wakes up to discover
that the coffin is in fact on fire but
yeah the the idea of it is the dream
the dream is the imaginary and the dream
incorporates the real what's happening
the the part of the house is on fire but
it incorporates the real in a in a
different sense in order to allow the
sleep to continue
but then in the dream
when the dream gets too close to the
real because he feels responsible for
his son's death and his son says can't
you see I'm burning
then the dream becomes too real so then
he wakes up to reality
and jijek's argument here is that uh
wokeness is actually a sleepness
allowing
the status quo to exist because people
get off by being morally Superior than
everyone else so as long as you're
morally Superior you get off yeah and
then that avoids uh any any real status
quo change so you're staving off the
Reel by being woke and doing your land
acknowledgments and canceling your
microaggression profs
and that's what's happening here and
whatever he calls real racism and sexism
um that's not dealt with I guess the
people that don't get to be involved in
the quote unquote discourse they get
they get left
what do you mean by that
well if they're not part if they're not
part of the University system or the the
social media system where these
arguments are getting made then they
don't get they're like they're the
people with the real issues whereas the
uh the woke Black Elite they don't have
real issues they're just making issues
and then everyone's cowing to them in
order to
feel guilt because their guilt feels
like they're paying for their internal
crimes I don't think that that's the
argument here I don't think that that's
right I think that he would say I don't
think that the people even
I think she would say that the woke who
are falling for this kind of dogmatic
approach to anti-racism or whatever
I don't think that his claim is they're
not experiencing real racism I'm pretty
sure he would say they are I think his
critique is with the way that that
addressing the racism is being the
imperative for how to react to it is the
woke part it's not the ex the fact that
their their experience of racism isn't
real
I'll just read it
it's exactly the same with much of the
ongoing woke movement the woke awaken us
to racism and sexism precisely to enable
us to go on sleeping they show us
certain realities so that we can go on
ignoring the true roots and depth of our
racial and sexual traumas oh okay which
is okay that last one [__] it I can make
exactly the same argument about
anti-wokness anti-wocus wokeness focuses
on its exceptional images and its
cherry-picked examples and it's Google
Alerts of the of the latest weirdo who
also happens to be trans and then using
that particular weirdo to demonstrate
that trans people shouldn't be
accommodated and at best they're all
nuts and it worsely represents the
downfall of civilization which is of
course not zizek's argument but the same
oh no no I mean
would agree with that he would say that
that's exactly the same thing like that
the structure they're both self they're
both like
um
uh reciprocally interacting reciprocally
nourishing
structures like the anti-woke in the
woke are two sides of the same coin
so do you think this article being
released publicly
um it's been retweeted by Jordan
Peterson for example do you think this
is waking people up or allowing people
to continue sleeping ideologically I
don't I think the the I think he
problematizes that binary
lokeness stands for its opposite that's
what he's saying there and then he gives
that strange explanation
I mean I guess not strange if you've
read Freud's interpretation of dreams
and you're used to it I'm not used to it
well part part of the reason I'm so
frustrated by this is that
the people that he is I mean this the
form of this and the form of a Ben
Shapiro segment is that conservatives
spend more time talking about trans
people than even trans people to talk
about trans people
and why it's so that every one of their
fungus brained viewers focuses on that
instead of the fact that their real
income has been declining since the 70s
so as long as you can get something mad
about something else then you will avoid
the real I mean isn't that true yeah I
agree with that I mean that's
that's I think also what's happening on
I mean
reality too like I mean I think there's
a lot of stuff like like I always think
about this this whole push to try to
change the names of streets
or change the names of things and it's
like I'm I always just think
like couldn't we just use the money
that's spent to change the signs and go
and I don't know for example like fix
the water system in indigenous reserves
like why are we
like and and for these symbolic gestures
that are just like on the level of kind
of culture War nonsense when we could
actually go make a difference to actual
people's lives who are who are
experiencing Injustice
yeah because then politics gets in the
way and nobody can do anything look
you've been saying this the whole time
look at this article in a vacuum it was
written last week it's not in a vacuum
why don't you fix the water in an
indigenous Community because it would
change people's lives laws are being
written with the intended effect of
preventing trans people from existing in
public or from getting meds now zizik's
not an idiot he knew this would cause a
reaction he's been trying to make
reactions for a long time and what he's
rhyming with here don't change your
gender too quick because everyone has
identity problems slow this [__] down
and then knowingly
him entering the media image exchange
War
who does this protect and who does it
harm
now this is a renewed topic for debate
people's medicine is a topic for debate
you know what changes then [__]
nothing
so writing this article is nothing more
than keeping people asleep
simply because now it's a topic for
political debate this article is the
[__] NyQuil
blame everything on wokism no this
article is that NyQuil yeah I mean I
think so
that's why I wanted to because because
you know that's why I wanted to focus on
the article because if you just do the
psychoanalytic free association thing
and follow your signifying chains then
it will be an interminable debate and
there will be no basis for anybody to
say you've missed the point no you've
missed the point how do you know well I
was just free associating so what am I
what what am I going to present to you
no I'm just looking at the points he's
making and the overall argument that's
that's why I took that tack because I
knew it would be interminable if we just
read into this whatever we feel like we
want to read into it then it's going to
be forever and then nothing's gonna get
done you know he says he says dude that
was the goal it's not he says the people
who are caving in
he says the people who are submitting to
woke demands really are guilty in
participating in Social domination but
the fact of their giving in to woke
demands is a way out of that guilt right
you you take on the guilt and then it
enables you to go on exploiting and
perpetuating the system of domination
right that's the that's what he's just
said and then he says wokeness stands
for its opposite you know the dream got
too real reality is the place we go to
escape the real that's what it is he was
sleeping and it became too real he
encountered the unbearably traumatic
character of his son burning in a coffin
and he suddenly woke up and he he went
to reality to escape the real right it's
all you're always running away from it
not facing it I don't know I don't know
what the point I don't know how you
transverse that fantasy you know
dreaming means fantasizing in order to
avoid confronting the real
but what happens when the dream becomes
too traumatic that's the real is that
traumatic kernel
and like you know how do you Sleepwalk
how do you navigate around your house
when you're fast asleep because there is
reality in your dream
but you know if your dream becomes
horrific if your house sets on fire
while you're asleep walking around and
then you're it reproduces it in your
dream somehow and you start melting or
something then you wake up not because
the house is on fire but because the
dream became too traumatic and you went
to the reality to escape the real right
and that's saying I I don't know how to
line this up here wokeness is
the
I don't know what the what's the thing
here being woke is like being asleep
and then being asleep the dream of the
wokeness in the sleeping State like I I
don't know how to [__] square it all
up someone else someone who's better
with this stuff's got to do it for me
[Music]
pills no he's just being being overly
concerned with the the discourse around
it and cowing doctors and having
professors have their their seminars
canceled
dealing with this is easier and I think
dealing with whatever he calls real
traumas as if uh those people aren't
dealing with real trouble I think you're
probably right that
you're right that is doing the same
thing in a way so like I think you're
right that but I still think that that
doesn't mean that the point he's making
is wrong
he's still participating in it though
I do just want to say quickly pills I'm
sorry for calling you anti-intellectual
you just said something that triggered
me there which is when people say we
shouldn't talk about things when they
affect real people's lives and
I think I didn't take that as it is
on that point okay
okay well in any case I still don't
think that you're actually
anti-intellectual I just think that the
reason I got interested in philosophy is
because you get to actually debate
questions that matter to people that's
what makes it good and interesting
so I just get very triggered when people
say things that sound like well for this
thing we're not allowed to do it and I'm
like uh
like without these cherry-picked
examples without this article without
this entire article if we just took the
last paragraph and applied it to land
acknowledgments which we've talked about
before on this show as just being the
absolutely most stupid useless and
almost insulting practices
yes people feel good we did a landed
acknowledgment before our lecture I have
a land acknowledgment in my [__] gym
like that I that I pay eighty dollars a
month to go into that's what
so like if that were the if that were
the issue at issue here then yes I'm all
for it but if you're gonna start it off
the way that he started it off
minimizing and then misrepresenting
of all things medical access which is
just the most basic material condition
you could ask for you kind of lose sight
of the rest of the point
land acknowledgments are wokeness
yeah it's the same thing it's the same
thing here you can make the same
structurally similar argument the land
acknowledgment is the real like you know
the the stealing of land is the
realities
that we confront ourselves with so we
can go on ignoring the true roots and
depth of our racial and sexual traumas
it's structurally the same thing like
you know land acknowledgment affectually
effectively stands for its opposite you
know the land is This Land is Our Land
right like it's it's not giving anything
back it's not land back it's not
reparations it's not reconciliation it's
just a [__] it's just a gesture
improving the material conditions
is painting it in this article it's the
same as wokeness land acknowledgment is
wokeness while we're putting everything
under wokeness as g-jac is doing here
black issues trans issues prison issues
issues with with um you know drugs and
Clinics and all all social justice is
now just being rebranded wokeness I
don't think that's a helpful part about
this argument and he could have more
historical attention to to what wokeness
is and where it came from instead of
just sort of accepting the terms of the
[__] culture war debate that's going
on right now because that's not what
wokeness is it's changed over time I
think I think I think if I was I know we
Eric and I've been pretty generous to
ziz Jack I think like stating the point
I feel like
he's trying to like I personally don't
think that he and this is maybe I'm just
projecting my own feelings about it
like how I feel which is that you know I
don't think that he has any problems
with trans people accessing their health
care or
um a lot of these things as much as it's
just noticing the backlash or the way or
kind of like the emotional reaction to
certain kinds of question raising that
happens or kind of maybe it's not so
much
right so like I think there's a way in
which let me see if I can say this more
clearly I think there's a way in which
you can agree with the position that is
dogmatically presented but disagree with
the fact that it's dogmatic
and I sort of feel that's the way I sort
of feel it's like I agree with TR with
uh trans rights but I don't like the way
it's sometimes dogmatically presented
and I think I feel that way and I feel
like wokeness
is in general whatever people think
about wokeness is generally a bunch of
[__] that I actually agree with from a
Justice perspective but hate the way
that it gets taken up in this kind of
dogmatic structure that then has these
kinds of weird contradictory demands
oh yeah yeah that's kind of a nice point
he made a little earlier about the
difference in form between the the
workshop and the seminar I I really
don't get this example and why he chose
those words but okay yeah one of them
the seminar you're supposed to be
open-minded work with the text the
meaning emerges slowly over time but
when you're in the workshop I guess I
don't know it doesn't really clarify
that it's like this in place yeah yeah
there's there's an implicit Dogma in
place and if anybody goes Strays from
that accepted but unspoken Dogma you are
hurting somebody you are harming you are
you you are labeled you know whatever
anti this anti that and he said that's
the bad those are the formal opposites
right like the one is is is yeah
dialectical and the other one is
automatic prescriptive it's hard to be
it's also really hard and this is I
think the Trap that he's fallen into
here even though and I do actually think
that some of the rhetoric he chose is
unfortunate as I've already said
but the trouble is just that it's really
a hard to actually present yourself in a
way that people see what you're doing
when you say I don't agree with the
Dogma
it's very easy for people to think oh
that means you don't agree with the
actual underlying thing that the Dogma
is pushing
it's really hard for people to do that
and you know I think off air pills has
kind of jokingly but maybe not so
jokingly been like well there are only
two positions that exist in the
spectacle it's like you can't have this
position in the Middle where you're kind
of against the Dogma but for the point
uh and yeah I mean maybe in the in the
in the spectacle it is impossible and
I'm gonna be heard as just being
anti-trans or whatever in this because
but when really I'm just anti-dogma I
mean it's a hair it's a hair that needs
splitting maybe accepting dogmatic
claims like that's what I'm [__]
interested in doing as an academic
splitting hairs
the dogma's the religious angle right
like if he's I mean that's a dangerous
paragraph the one where he seems to
equate feminism with some kind of
religious fundamentalism and that's why
the feminists stuck up for the Muslim
Students oh yeah like oh that yeah
exactly that's a little bit you know
wokeness draws on our reserves of
religious strength you know I mean
that's
that's an old you know okay like
critique of religion you know Hegel Marx
critique criticize religion now religion
is just like bad for all time I don't
know what's what's so bad about
something that can tap into our like
deeper religious
urges as human beings seem to have
I don't see I don't know yeah just yeah
that just seems dangerous to me to say
like yeah these like the feminists are
are also like feminism is also a
secularized religious Dogma like I I
don't know there are some questions I'd
like to ask
then then he gets to the point wokeness
secularized religious Dogma with all the
contradictions this implied I don't buy
into the
you know find religion and critique it
wherever it you find the religious
impulse and stomp on it wherever you
find it kind of well that's why I that's
why I prefer to I prefer to use the word
dogma as opposed to religion yeah like
we all know like yeah capitalism is is
is a religion yeah Walter Benjamin I
like that
money is money is the god and all this
what have we learned here I guess I was
surprised I was surprised by how
uh how much
I don't know uh
how much pills was against the article
and how much Eric was you know kind of
calling for a bit of a defense of what
the article's saying that was a bit
surprising to me
yeah I didn't even I don't know I didn't
even get to whether I agree or disagree
with what he's saying I mentioned a few
issues with his Framing and some
implications that I thought might be a
little problematic but otherwise I was
just
I am mostly surprised on how differently
we read it
yeah I thought I was gonna swoop in here
with a clear-headed reading you know
you know thesis I mean one evidence
point to evidence boom conclusion done
but we had very very different
perceptions of what was going on in this
article and that's uh and I could see
why he would do that but you know the
hermeneutics are not nothing exists in a
vacuum this was in written intentionally
to be interpreted this way we didn't
even talk about the and uh we didn't
even talk about the publication itself
compact I saw that which is another kind
of like dumb critique
even though I am suspicious yeah they
want everyone's voices to be heard but
everyone's kind of pointing out well
compacts are reactionary oh and this was
an article framed as a response to an
earlier article on guess which website
Compact and guess what happens when you
click on that article it's behind a
[__] paywall you can't see the
article that Zizek is talking to because
you have to pay compact to see it or
subscribe I don't know maybe it's a free
subscription I didn't check but this one
was free I clicked on it and the article
was there I click on this one that this
article is supposedly replying to a
heavy hitter replying to a previous
article in the same thing a little bit
of self-serving [__] going on here
expected I guess but
that's the frame that's the framework
that's that's the edge of the vacuum
that's the bag of the vacuum I don't
know how is that a good metaphor yeah
this is a compact article that's that's
whatever they did it worked yeah we
should we should wrap them uh they're
the devil and this is the dirt could we
could we do this as like maybe a patreon
episode and then we could see if people
get mad at us
and then we can release it to the public
based on that based on the patreon
reaction we owe the public an episode
but what okay what happened to all your
intellectual
free-floating Integrity I thought you
were just being intellectually honest I
don't know I'm trying to be it's an
attempt being intellectually honest is
never achieved it's always an attempt
you never know what you've said until a
bunch of angry people interpret what
you're saying
well it was a hot one in any case uh
thank you for listening to pillpod113
more on the patreon and uh yeah later
from us
[Music]